alors je vais commencer par vous parler
de philosophie et pas d'économie
viendrait à l'économie après alors vous
avez cité aristote moi je vais citer un
autre philosophe qui s'appelle platon
qui a écrit un livre qui a marqué toute
la pensée occidentale un livre qui
s'appelle le politique donc on est un
peu près en 370 avant avant jésus-christ
est dans ce livre
platon introduit la notion de juste
milieu alors il appelle pas ça le juste
milieu ils appellent ça la tempérance
mais l'idée à peu près la même plate ont
défini quatre vertus cardinales alors
des vertus cardinales ce sont des vertus
qui doivent servir de soubassement
autres un quart d'eau en latin ça veut
dire legault est donc ce sont des vertus
autour desquels doivent s'articuler les
autres et donc il ya chez platon quatre
vertus cardinales qui sont les suivantes
le courage la tempérance la prudence et
la tempérance et d'ailleurs ce sont des
vertus cardinales au fond que vous allez
retrouver non seulement chez tous les
philosophes grecs et aristote en effet
vale vale reprendre mais chez les
philosophes romain aussi cicéron va
reprendre ça et puis les grands auteurs
chrétiens toute la chrétienté va
reprendre ces quatre vertus cardinales
et ce qui est très intéressant à ce qui
m'intéresse moi en tant qu'économiste
c'est que le livre de platon s'appelle
bien le politique c'est à dire que
platon définit ses vertus parce que pour
lui ce sont les vertus qui sont
nécessaires à la conduite de l'action
publique
alors vous voyez que c'est pas toujours
évident le courage il ya beaucoup de
gens courageux dans l'action publique
mais parfois peut-être on manque aussi
un petit peu de courage ça peut ça peut
arriver
la justice alors la justice c'est un
idéal après lequel on court mais c'est
pas forcément toujours facile à définir
puis à des définitions différentes delà
de la justice
la prudence ça par contre je pense que
c'est une vertu qu'on retrouve assez
régulièrement plus couramment en tout
cas que le col courage par exemple et la
tempérance c'est très intéressant parce
que la tempérance c'est aujourd'hui très
difficile en réalité de faire vivre
cette vertu c'est très difficile quand
vous faites de la politique alors moi je
suis pas dans l'action politique je suis
dans l'analyse mais même quand vous
participez au débat public
cette question de la tempérance à voir
au fond un discours qui soit un discours
mesuré comme vous l'avez dit qu'il soit
un discours nuancé c'est devenu de plus
en plus difficile alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de façon très concrète avoir
un discours nuancé à quoi elle se
rattache en termes de politique
économique
cette idée de tempérance et c'est assez
simple elle se rattache à l'idée de
régulation et la régulation qui s'oppose
donc à la liberté totale d'un côté comme
à l'interdiction totale de l'autre cette
idée de régulation c'est donc une idée
je ne sais pas s'ils allaient du juste
milieu mais enfin en tout cas c'est une
idée nuancée qui à mon avis est l'idée
la plus juste et on en a jamais eu
autant besoin aujourd'hui parce que les
mutations technologiques et économiques
que nous traversons ce qu'on appelle la
troisième révolution industrielle c'est
à dire la convergence trois grands types
de technologies les technologies du
numérique les technologies de la
robotique et les technologies de
l'intelligence artificielle et bien
cette troisième révolution industrielle
elle est en train de changer la
technologie l'économie notre
organisation sociale et donc elles
nécessitent des régulations puis vous
donner un exemple très concret très
précis pour faire comprendre encore
encore mieux comme beaucoup d'entre vous
d'entre nous je voyage beaucoup et quand
je voyage un peu loin dans un pays que
je connais mal
j'aime bien aller rendre visite au maire
de la ville que je dans laquelle je
réside et ces dernières années à chaque
fois
alors évidemment les les gens savent que
je suis économiste c'est la façon dont
je me présente mais à chaque fois dans
90% des cas que je me trouve à berlin à
los angeles ou au caire j'en sais rien
ou à rabat on me dit mais qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec airbnb
est-ce que airbnb on me dit d'un côté
c'est formidable parce que c'est de
l'hébergement touristique et donc il
faut développer airbnb et de l'autre
c'est un immense problème parce que ce
sont des surfaces qui sont des logements
en moins parce que ce qui devient une
résidence touristique n'est plus un
logement
or on a besoin de davantage de logements
et donc qu'est ce que je dois faire en
tant que mère parce que d'un côté je
dois encourager airbnb et de l'autre je
dois décourager airbnb sans quoi vous
voyez que l'action politique est quelque
chose d'extrêmement compliqué puisque
vous faites face en permanence à des
injonctions contradictoires l'opinion
publique vous demande en termes je dis
pas ça du tout pour dédouaner les
politiques mais enfin quand même un
petit peu l'opinion publique vous
demande toujours de faire des choses qui
sont absolument contradictoires entre
elles raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle
dès que vous êtes dans l'action publique
vous devenez un peu plus l'air vous
devenez forcément impopulaire puisque
vous prenez forcément des décisions qui
heurte un certain nombre d'intérêts
alors évidemment si je reprends mon
exemple d'airbnb à la solution à ça
c'est pas de laisser faire parce que
quand on dit que ça prend des surfaces
de logements c'est juste et en même
temps la solution c'est pas d'interdire
parce que il ya des endroits y compris
dans paris on a besoin d'avoir davantage
d'hébergements touristiques et donc la
solution c'est de trouver des
régulations qui sont un peu complexes
qui sont un peu fine et voyez ce type
d'idées c'est très difficile aujourd'hui
à faire passer dans le débat public et
ça m'inquiète beaucoup
en réalité c'est ce qui m'inquiète le
plus ce qui m'inquiète le plus j'y
reviendrai dans un instant c'est pas
l'évolution des technologies c'est pas
l'évolution du travail s'est pas
l'évolution des grands enjeux
géopolitiques bien évidemment peuvent
sembler anxiogène mais c'est pas ça au
fond le fond du sujet c'est que dans le
débat public il est de plus en plus
difficile de tenir des positions qui
sont des positions nuancées
à l'image de
de l'exemple que je viens de prendre
avec airbnb et s'il est difficile s'il
est de plus en plus difficile de prendre
des positions qui sont nuancés c'est
pour deux raisons
deux raisons qui me semble-t-il sont
assez bien documenté et là je m'adresse
aux plus jeunes d'entre vous contre
lesquels je pense
il faut absolument lutter ce sont les
deux grands enjeux de notre civilisation
mais qui en même temps peuvent vraiment
je pense détruire notre civilisation la
civilisation occidentale
elle est menacée d'une part et je vais
m'attarder quelques instants sur chacun
de ces deux phénomènes parce que c'est
très important mais notre civilisation
elle est menacée d'une part par le
phénomène des fakes news tout ce que
l'on appelle la poste vérité j'y viens
dans quelques instants
et elle est menacée par le fait qu'elle
est dominé par la peur ce qui domine
aujourd'hui les sociétés développées les
sociétés occidentales mais même les
sociétés développées en général c'est le
sentiment de peur et si vous faites le
produit d'effets news x la peur vous
avez non seulement évidemment quelque
chose qui explique qu'ils soient de plus
en plus difficile de tenir des propos
nuancés
peu importe qu'ils soient juste la
vérité malheureusement je vais y venir
n'est pas valorisé dans nos sociétés
mais ce sont 7 un cocktail c'est un
produit la peur x l'ephec news qui
vraiment peut détruire notre
civilisation est donc je pense que il
faut qu'on combatte ça avec énormément
d'ardeur alors le thème de fait qu'une
terme de fait que news le terme de
postes vérité post trousses vous le
savez c'est un terme qui est entré
officiellement dans le dictionnaire en
2000 en 2016
donc c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
récent le mensonge est quelque chose qui
a toujours existé
y compris dans le débat public les fakes
news
c'est quelque chose qui a toujours
existé y compris dans le débat public
il a toujours été difficile de dire la
vérité un de mes maîtres intellectuelle
qui s'appelait raymond aron
avait dit à la fin de sa vie à mon
dernier coauteur de de l'année luc ferry
pour ne pas le nommer il lui avait dit
toute ma vie toute ma vie j'ai essayé de
dire la vérité
le bilan c'est que cela ne m'a jamais
rien apporté de bon je pense que c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement profond je
comprends parfaitement ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a voulu dire ce qu'il a voulu dire
c'est que il faut quand même rechercher
la vérité mais il faut pas il faut le
dire mais il ne faut pas en chercher un
bénéfice immédiat
sinon on risque d'être on risque d'être
déçu
donc le phénomène n'est pas nouveau mais
il a pris récemment une acuité
particulière beaucoup plus forte en
réalité que ce que l'on connaissait dans
les années soixante dix où dans les
années 80 et pour deux raisons je crois
la première raison vous la connaissez
tous c'est bien évidemment le fait que
les réseaux sociaux ont généré une
culture de l'instantanéité et une
culture de la non vérification qui met à
mal ou est entretenu par beaucoup de
biais cognitifs
je renvoie au livre absolument
extraordinaire de mon ami gérald bronner
notamment son dernier ouvrage qui
s'appelle déchéance de nationalité qu'il
faut vraiment lire parce que ils
expliquent parfaitement les raisons pour
lesquelles ces biais cognitifs au fond
sont entretenus par les réseaux sociaux
n'ont pas quels réseaux sociaux soient
mauvais en soi on peut faire un
excellent usage des réseaux sociaux mais
il faut essayer de contrôler les biais
cognitifs que l'on a en tête alors un
biais cognitifs vous savez c'est quelque
chose dans votre cerveau en mode de
mécanismes du cerveau qui vous empêche
de raisonner correctement je vous donne
un exemple très concret un biais
cognitifs courant c'est de croire ce que
l'on craint quand vous avez peur de
quelque chose
vous pensez que cette chose là est vrai
peu importe que ce soit faux
si vous le craignez vous allez
démultiplier la probabilité c'est le
phénomène des gens qui ont peur en avion
tu as peur en avion pourquoi tu as peur
un avion parce qu'un avion peut
s'écraser
la probabilité elle existe elle est de
l'ordre de 1 sur 6 millions ou 7
millions donc vraiment vous allez mourir
d'autres choses c'est certain mais à
partir du moment où on le craint on a
tendance à y croire et notre cerveau va
considérer que cette probabilité n'est
pas de 1 sur 4 millions ou de 20 sur 6
millions mais de 10%
voyez ça c'est typiquement un billet un
biais cognitifs un autre biais cognitifs
et là je m'adresse aux jeunes sur lequel
j'attire votre attention c'est très
important c'est le fait que toutes les
études montrent que sur les réseaux
sociaux
nous valorisons le contenu est pas le
contenant ce que cela signifie très
concrètement c'est que nous avons
tendance à croire à des informations si
nous sommes d'accord avec ces
informations peu importe la personne qui
les a proféré ce qui est quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave parce que évidemment
vous avez des personnes plus ou moins
compétente et ça c'est la deuxième
raison au fond en plus des réseaux
sociaux qui explique qu'on ait une
prolifération de fait que nous
aujourd'hui légale et harry
l'égalitarisme ambiant cette idée
incroyablement démagogiques contre
laquelle je me bats et vous devez vous
battre
cette idée selon laquelle tout se vaut
et cette idée selon laquelle tous les
avis se valent
tout le monde est touché par ça le grand
débat au niveau public les
brainstormings en entreprise un
brainstorming dans les entreprises
vous savez avec de règle en général qui
sont étiquetés au début du brainstorming
première règle toutes les idées se
valent et sont bonnes
deuxième règle dit tout ce qui vous
passe par la tête de conseils que je
vous conseille de ne jamais respecté
parce que dira tout ce qui passe par la
tête non l'intelligence est censé faire
filtre et toutes les idées se valent non
j'ai des idées bonnes
il ya des idées mauvaises j'ai des idées
vrai il ya des idées fausses mais il ya
des idées vrai la vérité ça existe le
mensonge ça existe tout ne se vaut pas
il y a des gens plus compétents que
d'autres et à considérer ce qui est le
problème du débat public aujourd'hui
qu'on doit en permanence
m une personne pour face à une personne
contre on ne rend pas service à la
société parce que je vous dis comme je
le pense
mais quand on met un pro vaccin fasse un
anti vaccins je pense extrêmement
malsain de considérer que leur avis se
valent et donc il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive qu'on se remobilise pour arriver
à lutter contre ça parce que là encore
je vous le disais il ya quelques
instants
ce phénomène défectueuse il a toujours
existé mais ce qui est très nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que la vérité n'est
plus une valeur au fond et vous avez un
certain nombre de gens qui mentent mais
qui n'ont même plus l'impression de
mentir y compris dans le débat dans le
débat politique
vous avez des gens au fond qui considère
que tout se vaut que toutes les idées se
valent et que proférer un mensonge n'a
pas moins de valeur ça n'est pas moins
valable que dire quelque chose de vrai
ça c'est tout simplement mortel pour la
démocratie vous comprenez pourquoi c'est
que s'il ya plus de vérité s'il ya plus
de choses des choses fausses il ya plus
de débat public
s'il ya plus de débat public il ya plus
de démocratie s'il ya plus de démocratie
c'est notre civilisation qui s'effondre
ce en quoi nous comprenons pourquoi il
est difficile de tenir un jugement
nuancé
deuxième grande difficulté de nos
sociétés nos sociétés sont très
largement dominés par la peur comme le
dit lui une autre de mes co auteur
récente julia de funès
on a peur de tout
on a peur de ce qu'on mange on a peur de
ce qu'on respire on a peur des chinois
de donald trump
on a peur des populismes et on a des
peurs à transitive on a peur de la
grippe et on a peur du vaccin contre la
grippe qui sont deux peurs absolument
intransitive entre elles vous devez
choisir et d'ailleurs je conseille au
passage d'avoir plutôt peur de la grippe
et donc comprenez bien que cette peur là
encore n'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau
ce qui est nouveau c'est le fait qu'elle
est devenue une qualité alors c'est
quelque chose qui remonte à quelques
années et qui a été développé par un
très grand philosophe un parieur qui
s'appelait hans yonath un très grand
philosophe allemand qui en 1979 a publié
un livre très important qui s'appelle le
principe responsabilité qui est un très
grand livre de philosophie dans lequel
il explique que la peur est une ristic
ça signifie que la peur n'est pas un
sentiment comme les autres selon lui
selon lui la peur est un outil qui nous
protège et donc il faut avoir peur il
faut avoir peur parce que c'est la peur
qui va nous protéger
je pense que c'est une impasse
philosophique totale puisque la peur ne
nous protège pas elle nous paralyse et
là il faut revenir aux philosophes
antiques ce qui nous protège c'est la
prudence ce qui nous protège c'est la
tempérance
mais ça n'est pas la peur on a
parfaitement le droit d'avoir peur
il m'arrive moi même d'avoir peur dans
certaines situations
bien évidemment c'est pas la peur qui
est mauvaise ce qui est mauvaise c'est
l'acceptation de la peur ce qui est
mauvais c'est le fait que nous avons
déculpabiliser la peur quand j'étais
petit mes parents me disaient situé dans
une pièce noire n'est pas peur si tu
vois une araignée n'ai pas peur
aujourd'hui la société vous dit si tu
vois une araignée et peur parce qu'elle
peut de piqué c'est très dangereux et
donc éloigne toi d'où l'immense succès
et là vous voyez que nous sommes au
coeur de notre sujet l'immense succès de
tous les livres dits de collapse au
logis qui vous expliquent que c'est
foutu que le monde s'effondre qui a plus
rien à faire notamment dans le domaine
du réchauffement climatique et que de
toute façon notre civilisation alors là
c'est même pire que notre civilisation
que notre planète
court à sa perte je suis en total
désaccord avec ça je pense que le
problème du réchauffement climatique du
dérèglement climatique est un problème
extrêmement grave et je pense que nous
disposons de beaucoup de ressources pour
le régler c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle là aussi on est en plein
dans notre sujet j'entends de plus en
plus de gens me dire ah mais il faut pas
il faut pas faire d'enfant parce que on
est déjà trop nombreux alors faut qu'on
soit moins nombreux mais c'est absurde
fait des enfants qui seront bien formés
qui iront dans le bon établissement
scolaire et qui vont aider à résoudre le
problème du réchauffement climatique
paraît beaucoup plus utile que de ne pas
faire d'enfant est pire que ça et ce
sera ma conclusion est là je m'adresse
aux parents parce que je suis pas
content parce que j'entends parfois des
parents me dire ab c'est horrible quel
monde on leur laisse vouloir laisser un
monde en bien meilleur état que le monde
dans lequel vous êtes né voilà la vérité
ça a été là encore très bien documenté
par un certain nombre d'auteurs steven
pinker johan norberg y en a beaucoup
vous pouvez vous y référer dans le
domaine économique
on vit dans un monde dans lequel la
pauvreté n'a jamais été aussi faible
contrairement à ce qu'on vous raconte
partout les inégalités n'ont jamais été
aussi faibles qu'aujourd'hui les
libertés n'ont jamais été aussi étendue
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des guerres bien
évidemment pierre servant est l'un des
plus grands spécialistes de ce sujet
mais quand vous regardez le nombre de
morts liées à des conflits armés
il y en a beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
que c'était le cas il y a vingt ou
trente ans nous avons des problèmes bien
évidemment j'évoquais la question du
dérèglement climatique
mais la question du des règles des
dérèglements climatiques il s'agit pas
d'en avoir peur s'agit de régler
complètement différent et pour le régler
c'est pas la peur qui est bonne
conseillère
ce qui est bon ce qui sera bonne
conseillère c'est la créativité
l'intelligence l'innovation dans les
entreprises et et de bonne régulation de
bonne politique
public du juste milieu qui soit efficace
mais qui en même temps soit acceptée par
les gens parce que si elles sont
rejetées pour les gens ça ne sert à rien
c'est pas de l'optimisme
il faut pas être optimiste pour essayer
de développer de pensée de mettre en
application une politique du juste
milieu
je déteste soit qu'on classe dans les
optimistes je suis ni optimiste et puis
vous connaissez le mot de bernanos à un
optimiste est un imbécile heureux un
pessimiste est un imbécile malheureux
donc ce sont deux catégories qui sont à
éviter absolument
ce qui doit nous animer ce qui doit nous
animer c'est la lucidité la lucidité la
vérité et la lucidité
c'est ça ce qui va nous aider ces
prochaines données voilà
[Applaudissements]